pfl is the world's finest transporter
authority before the pandemic began that
we managed to reduce the deficit we i
inherited by more than 71 increased cash
balances
by 16 but also reduced year-on-year our
operation operating cost by more than a
billion pounds and we helped contribute
towards the national economy more than
40 billion pounds net
our city contributes we're really proud
of the capital city to do so the only
reason tfl has challenges is because of
the pandemic londoners followed the
government's advice didn't use public
transport and our affairs plummeted and
there are 17 days left until the
short-term deal we have with the
government runs out and we've been
trying really hard to get around the
table with the government to ensure
we've got a financial deal going forward
because if we don't we've got to balance
the budget we're going to set for next
year unless the government gives us
support we need i worry about the
consequences for our city and our
country as well
we expecting this every few months then
some ultimatum that you've about to run
out of money and say the government must
cough up
no we've been asking for the last
18 months for a long term uh deal for at
tfl every transfer authority in the
world gets support from a central
government
we get the lease support and we've
agreed by 2023 to get no revenue support
from the government new york paris
madrid tokyo all the cities around the
globe receive proper support from their
government london's different because of
a deal reached between george osborne
and boris johnson but also
because 72 percent of our services are
paid for by fares compared to 38 48 of
other cities so in the absence of
customers
uh we've got no recourse but to ask for
support from the government what i'm
saying to the government
is because we need a national recovery
which is contingent upon a london
recovery which is contingent upon tfl
final cylinders and let's work together
to get a long-term teal for tfl
so we avoid a car led recovery so we
avoid a return to the decline we had in
the 70s and 80s of public transplant
let's work together for a national
recovery so services will grind to halt
is that what you're saying basically
just outline what might happen if you
don't get your money
so by january we'll have to make tough
decisions about reducing tubes uh
services bus services counseling
contracts give you an idea of the sort
of uh things we're talking about uh and
i call this managed decline it is almost
a 20 reduction in our bus services
across our city 100 routes could be uh
cut and almost 10 percent
reduction in cheap services
uh could could even be a tube line being
removed but also us stopping ordering uh
the buses that are built in uh balamina
four kirk scarborough uh gulford uh are
having to cancel the trains that are
built in gould and other parts of the
country there are 43 000 jobs across the
country in the supply chain that we're
really proud to um support and we need
expertise across the country we can't do
it ourselves
i worry about the consequences for the
country not just because london won't be
helping in the national recovery but
also because we'll be able to
honor the contracts we've entered into
or enter into new contracts